Uh,
we decided to come outside and try and experiment out here while the weather was
nice and dry. What we've got inside that huge beaker is water.
And we put in an indicator called phenol failing.
So at neutral that's colorless,
but once we put this other chemical in there, sodium hydroxide,
the sodium hydride will react with the water and it should be a very vigorous
reaction. Um, it produces sodium hydroxide, which is a base,
and that will therefore turn the solution. Uh, pink.
[Inaudible].
Sodium hydride is really quite an interesting compound.
I often say that,
but I think sodium hydride is particularly interesting because it
contains the hydride iron, which is H minus,
let me explain here. I have a rather crude model. This is a sodium atom,
and this is a hydrogen atom. And in the sodium atom,
there is one electron, which is in the outer shell.
And in sodium hydride in the solid one of these electrons is
transferred from the sodium to the hydrogen.
So you have sodium plus where the outer electron has been removed.
And over here,
you have eight minus that's hydrogen atom when extra electron.
[Inaudible].
These irons are in the solid,
and when you dissolve them in water,
what happens is they dissolve? So you get an,
a plus and H minus in solution,
but the hydrogen does not hold onto its electron very
strongly.
And the electron is easily removed by reaction with water.
As they drop the sodium hydride into the water. First of all,
it hits the surface.
Then it begins to dissolve and as it begins to dissolve,
it forms NH plus H minus,
and the H minus can then react with water. Water,
as you know is H2O. If you take H minus plus H2O,
it goes to H two hydrogen gas and OHA minus,
which is the hydroxide Dianne, which is what makes things alkaline.
So we then have a weight minus in the solution.
The H minus can then interact with the fin of Darlene,
which goes from colorless to red or pink,
depending on the concentration. So overall,
what happens when you drop it in,
there is a great puddling as the hydrogen gas comes out and it comes through.
Right?
[inaudible].
Sometimes it depends on the particular reaction conditions.
The hydrogen can touch fire and you can get big flames. It looks good,
but good chemists shouldn't get big flames.
[Inaudible].